- And your wife, Abby, I just
noticed. In the audience.
Yes. And your kids are new
to Southern California.
Y'all just moved here.
How is it?
- It's amazing, we love LA, so much.
- Yeah! Well, welcome to We
Love LA week. That's fitting.
- Thank you, I know, it's perfect.
- So what's the most LA thing
that you've gotten into?
- Well, for the first week,
our new neighbors started
dropping little gifts off
on our stairs. It was so sweet.
Just welcome to the neighborhood.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And my kids kept saying
they keep giving us these pretty rocks.
And we started having
pretty rocks all over.
They're crystals apparently.
- [Kelly] Yes, you get a lot of-
- This is a very LA thing.
You have crystals. I
don't know what they are,
but they're pretty.
- You charge them with the moon,
I don't know if you've heard.
- Okay, so I'm not there yet.
- Put them outside. No,
I know, I'm telling you,
this happens to me too.
I've got, that's the gift,
I think a lot of people
give out here. Yeah.
- [Woman] Pretty rocks, yeah.
- Well, but they are pretty.
And here's the thing. If
it works or not, I'm down.
- I'll take it all.
I need all the help I can get.
- If it works or not, I'm like, sure.
I'll put it in the moon and charge it.
Just wear it on my body.
- Tish had a headache
the other day and I said,
just put this by your head.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] Did it work?
- No, we needed Advil, yeah.
(Kelly laughs)